whatever does this started dating is
this rice well you know what so the kid
the boyfriends yeah yeah she had one
that was not a nice boy and it was like
they're just it's innocent enough but I
was like so this kid I want to meet this
kid something like okay I want to meet
you want to hang out with him I want to
meet him and then you can hang out with
him in a safe environment she's like
what's a safe environment dad and
everything is the attitude so all of a
sudden this kid comes over anyone ups me
he brings his mom genius thing is he's
so sweet and she is like steamrolling me
all the time and then he's like he's
seeing her like she's being rude to me
she'd be mean to him like if you're not
nice to him he might not want to be
hanging around you and this isn't this
is a keeper this dude is really nice
he's cool he went to the graduation she
just graduated last week he went to the
graduation with us he's like really
sweet I'm like okay well do the perfect
scenario is to find one boy well she's
with forever but he did one-up me I was
like ready I had the whole thing I had a
couple my buddies they're all sudden his
mom and I'm like hey so what do you do
at school do you have any
extracurricular activities
just like just completely just slap me
[Music]
you